"Most major air pollutants cannot be seen,
although large amounts of them concentrated
in cities are visible as smog". So this
actually feels decent. It's not as cleanly
written as I might like, but it doesn't
seem like there's any outright errors,
especially where they're underlined. So "of
them", well the "them" is referring to the
"major air pollutants". So this completely
cool. "Large amounts of them concentrated
in cities", well that's just saying that
these are the "large amounts" amounts of
the air pollutants "concentrated in
cities". This is making grammatical sense,
"are visible", so we're talking about
something that's plural so it completely
makes sense to use the plural form of the
verb, so "are visible as smog". So this
makes complete grammatical sense. So I
would say that this has no error.